what do we got again the prize is 40 25
15 that's it you don't get top three you
get no granola bars time control one
minute type war zone rated average
rating is actually a bit lower than what
is usual usual usual usually it's more
around twenty one hundred thirty seconds
time time is the handicap ending in 30
minutes you have to have an experience
level of fifty to get in and we got 21
16 just reading off some of these
ratings 20 21 17 18 23 16 15 seconds
before this one gets fired up here here
we go the bullet zone 126 players at
this moment here we go Jackson this was
one of the last guys let it played here
we go did he do some home cooking he
might did some home cooking get that
bishop looking to trap it Oh get my
knight to this square right here
incoming and then mate snip tonight oh
wait wait wait wait take this just casts
on my knight oh I'm on the Queen it'd be
nice if I took the Queen for once
oh I do and I'm out of the night Oh
to castled they can't castle
hit the Queen oh oh oh come on we need
resignation this is beat isn't it back
to tournament yes I was the only one to
get it win or the only the first one to
finish I should say okay 29 here we go
double those points and rest assured you
will not be clicking on the resign
button this time okay here we go
b5 let's get this in d5 oh they don't
move like that
and let's push that night around and I
want this square please can I get there
here we go here we go
even if even I want to get a connect to
pass pawn there we go
that's nice I'm going to do this even if
it's wrong and then pinpoint this oh
hang on hang on my King might have to
run run King oh let's do this no no no
no let's go here light square bishop its
castle its castle and then get this
Knight out of here quickly
oh I'm in a fork I'm in a fork oh oh oh
but I'm going to pinpoint that pawn I
should have taken here pin pin and then
Bishop here next okay I got something
good oh this is has to be good right
here let's uh let's take let's take
again let's take again I should have
thrown into check somewhere around there
okay let's do this first and then cut
that King off this is a one King and
pawn endgame if I could um get the rooks
off right has to be a rook and pawn
in-game okay let's get this and then
this is going to be strong right I
should have cut the King off let's get
back here how much time do I have do I
have enough time let's come here I
should have thrown in a check first and
are they going to take okay good these
two pawns so far advanced are equivalent
to let's not do that
not so fast here we go
check next let's take that rook and then
take these puns no stalemate no
stalemate here we go
another Queen triple Queen attack back
to tournament six six two six six two
medicine for goat is up there we had a
wild one the last time we met in this
tournament I should maybe throw those H
pawns down throw those H pawns
back to tournament oh they were fear and
maybe the H pond attack 12:6
a quick resigner here we go let's give
it a whirl here let's see if I could
psych them out here each pond attack
maybe d5 weaknesses light squares
where's the bishop going to go is it
going to retreat oh let's see
give me the light squares uh-oh uh-oh
bishop in is going to be brutal can I
get there I'm gonna go with it
even though they could get upon bishop
takes okay I'm still gonna kind of run
with it they're giving me their
LightScribe Bishop how they get out of
this check and then a crop he's in a
crossfire or maybe he's not he's not in
a crossfire he's not in a crossfire but
this King is dead I should have turned
this check
oh let's kick the night away and then
smash through here rook takes and then
rook to II no not quite I got to chase
this mmm let's do that there's a lot of
pins a lot of crazy stuff okay this is
good rook to d2 is the knight dead the
knight is actually running out of
squares oh I didn't see that
let's take care with check and then take
the knight with check and then take the
rook or even play to d2 next okay I got
this I got this here resign I have a
flight square for my King and I have
this covered by my queen maybe they were
trying to be sneaky there they might
have been trying to be sneaky um trying
to be sneaky
oh that's that's what am i doing just
move go go go go go go how much time do
I have
oh that's me that's good I didn't
realize 2012 six 2012 six six four four
less than twenty five a lot of time left
I want to try and run away with this one
can that happen they want to draw and I
don't want to draw I want to win I want
to win and I did not want to capture
like that but we're going to have to try
and make it work here definitely gonna
have to try and make this work though so
I'm okay with um karate chop the Queen
okay let's do this and get my bishop
here even if it's taken
I am restore my pawn structure which is
nice let's get my king here off of that
same file and push this guy a little bit
and get my majority going over here it's
not a majority I lied let's do this and
then are they gonna restore my Knights
are my final structure I'm in trouble
I'm in trouble I have to defend okay
let's do this he kicked away I want to
keep my Bishop on this diagonal
I need my king over here to defend my
pond I don't like devoting my pieces to
the defense of them so right here I want
my king here come on King okay
who stands better let's guard this and
then play this and then g5 and then here
we go okay I have Oh No whew that was a
close collar right there let me tell you
that was what you call a close call
right there
I want that palm maybe they'll miss it
yes that's what I like to see a missed
move oh let's just get up no let's do
this
I could promote with check then if they
actually played bishop they're all there
being sneaky they're being sneaky
what are you doing why are they being so
sneaky
let's just promote here that's what I'm
going to do I'm gonna give check there
we go now it's a lot cleaner now it's a
lot cleaner let's get this clean adjust
enough fuel left here back to tournament
30 2012 1210 medicine for go right here
in second come down to the wire against
the goat there you come down to the wire
alright Oh way leg this is the one of
the first times I think where maybe I
can catch them in a quick one get the
Queen not fall for it that fall for
those little tricks that I pull nope I
haven't none of it having none of those
tricks
come on each pun let's chop chop chop
some more let's do this
I think get my knight oh okay on the
bishop Queen trade go for Queen trade
let's do this first eight pawns when a
pawns attack oh that was a mouse slip on
their part and I didn't take advantage
of it I want to pinpoint this pawn that
could be annoying the bishop is
unprotected hit it whoa it's unprotected
okay in-betweener
this is good no the a pawn will run fast
oh I shouldn't have given that up so
easily
that's alright my king is in a good spot
this is a passed pawn - let's get it
rolling let's get going here trying to
be sneaky again hang on let's watch both
of them my king
pac-man mode there we go gobble up the F
pawn and then push that guy go King go
King there we go let's get back over
here let's come here this pond all
isolated puns this one wants to run no
now this one
Oh chucka ruski stepladder coming up
check they're looking for stalemate no
stalemate no steal me check me back to
tournament 42 2020 nope
call it 30 20 who's that who has 30 I
couldn't catch the name in time Benko is
going to be challenged it's going to be
challenged I need to support it now we
play here and then here and then let's
start a check in see how they block it I
might get the a file let's try a check
in are they going to pin my knight let's
play here I want to play this I don't
want their LightSquared bishop to get
out they're going to get out if okay
let's let's go with this I took my
Queens your rook to e8 I'm on d6 I'm
going to play Knight to a3 if Knight b6
and then a a5 and Knight back to c4
Bishop to f4 now d6 is under fire here
we go that can be very inconvenient to
have to deal with and I probably could
have taken here I need a flight square
and I think that pawns falling soon
maybe please Knight to h5 Bishop back to
h2 and then Knight to e4 and then I'm
piling up on d6 that's where I want to
focus my attention this point right here
pawn push takes takes Knight here and
then c6
open file it's the only open file let's
get there and now here we go
knight c6 this is what I was talking
about okay f6 f6 f6 they miss f6 what
did I miss
oh oh okay let's take care and let's
give check I have a flight Square I'm
looking for Megan - or what's close to
being a main - on g7 can't be avoided
it's guard this here we go mayn't next
back to tournament that was a pretty
quick 156 3030 28:19 art has 30 okay I
got more games in than anyone else so
far Tim Tim Tim Tim alright let's go Tim
Tim Loza what's his name let's try this
maybe I can make this work better
okay let's chop that chop that trade
Queens we are trading Queens okay
and let me get rid of that pond okay now
that's a freebie that is what you call a
freebie I can't rely upon my night
I guess playing here next to pass pond
it's a free pond it's even if it falls
but now if it falls then they work
themselves into a pin and I'm hitting
this pond if the night takes I could
also pin it let's do this
hit the night it's got to be good there
we go this is winning a deadly fork
incoming incoming deadly Fork
resignation they see what's coming are
they're going to another the clock tick
no don't let your clock tick there we go
let's get that in and then take the
night out so I could play here next okay
let's just do that
play Rick over down can't be avoided or
cannon the bishop moves no let's stop
this the bishop might want to get on
that diagonal let's get this pawn up and
then have my king play a little bit more
to take care my king involved stop that
give a check if the pawn pushes and then
take and how close to just taking that
bishop and then getting my king a bit
closer let's do it this is a one King
and pawn endgame so let's keep things
really simple King centralization that
might be sneaky with this pawn move they
might try to be sneaky back to
tournament 72 42 40 40 29 16 minutes
left mate X art medicine for go here we
go let's try c4 and then okay let's go
with the double fee and keto pretty move
that okay they're giving their dark
square bishop up I'm okay with doubled
pawns because now it's the age pawn
attack you gave up your let's get that
guy
there gave up here we go let's let's
insist I insist that the position open
up over here where you no longer have
your bishop around to watch over things
so my queen is going to try her best to
be a pest and that rhymed and I didn't
know okay
let's um I'm okay with trades that's all
right I'll work with this get my king
here I want one pair of rooks to be off
the board that way I'd have to worry
about rook d3 and now let's insist on
this maybe f5 I could be getting in
Knight f5 in particular here we go
tricks are not only for kids Knight f6
push looking to Queen I miss played it
let's come over here and then okay the
King gets to run to the corner that's
kind of sad isn't it okay or not
all right I have this still I want my
rook over here why is what is it doing
in the other spots I could pre move this
and just gobble up these pawns and then
push my C pawn next right back to
tournament 90 90 56 54 54 less than 15
halfway there halfway there
pair me up 90 56 way leg again here we
go what are they doing do they I moved
they're not moving
did they disconnect now they didn't
disconnect oh right here it could be
killer
they're stopping it I should probably
still do this though let's do this
before they do it okay now keep my
bishop around d3 I could take and then
d3 is under fire okay they were well
aware of that
let's stop the expansion with b4 let's
get my knight doing something else not
my pond by night I want to get it to b3
b3 okay here we go
oh okay actually c3 if they push c3 c3
incoming this has to be good I think
I'll let steak here first and okay now
Knight here are actually bishop okay I'm
dropping that pawn but I'm on d3 at the
end of this on d3 I'm going to take this
because this is a passed pawn I want to
get rid of their dark square bishop oh
oh they're on a bunch of stuff oh I
missed that 28 seconds oh I have to
defend oh this is no good
what what's going on why are they giving
me that no am I gonna get this I queen
with check and then they're ready to
give me oh wait let's give check here
and let's do this flight Square run King
run King okay okay I got a flight square
right is everything okay oh I want to
give check right here check on f3 check
is this leading to mate mmm
what do we got check they got to take
and then mate Oh Oh as I lucky duck on
that one I was
lucky duck okay integral integral okay
let's play in the center let's hit this
I have a wonderful Center a wonderful
Center and an even more wonderful center
and they need a more wonderful Center
and my king is going to march right up
the heart of this chessboard wait do you
see I think I think that's what he wants
to do he wants to march right up the gut
right up the gut so let's see if we
could make that happen let's see if we
can make that happen starting with this
but then okay let's take like that I was
getting nervous there for a second okay
ah let's take this my king is happy
where he's at and let's watch over this
pawn rook rook to a okay let's do this
my king is in a good spot
all right it's got to be open file mmm
if that pawn moves too fast
okay let's lock down on this and then
let's come back here put pressure on
this no no hang on where's that King
gone okay now the rook has to actually
stay passive now in the meantime my king
could sneak in get behind this past
problem before it's too late
and look for some mates kind of dance
around Oh back here force that and then
come back let's come back here for just
a second let's do this there we go now
we got this 11 seconds is a lot of time
can't stop both of these guys lock down
on that structure these two actually
Trump the three my opponents playing
very fast let me do similar okay no
stalemate please back to tournament
there we go 130 108 medicine forego is
um
not letting this be easy at all here 130
108 let's go another person with 108
less than 11 way leg again oh man
why do I keep getting black against him
oh here we go let's not allow that to
happen let's see if they play the night
move I'm gonna come all the way back no
not all the way back actually let's do
this okay so let's do that and then get
this in
pin pin coming up let's get this up c5
c5 maybe c4 on the Queen oh I should
have done that the bishops going to go
no they're not going to go there OC 3
I want to get b5 in there we go there we
go this is a nice lockdown I'm on h4
let's go here and oh I have everything
covered on the dark squares thankfully I
don't want to give up my dark square
bishop
so let's come back here I want to get my
knight on the light squares Oh Oh my
Knights going to be in a pin oh this is
dangerous this is very very dangerous
okay I'm going to go with this trade if
it happens we're going to have it we're
even with time I could also maybe take
here in some variations let's get this
Queen out of here okay and here we go
this is a passed pawn maybe over here
Bishop takes a bishop takes B and then
get these pot hang on let's watch over
this guy and let's get a check in no
let's not do that
okay I got three connected passed pawns
rook takes Knight takes let's get this
pawn pushing let's guard this I don't
want any checks there I can check with
my bishop
check I'm on the rook check here pan
there it is I'm on the night you might
want to give a check first let's do this
I just have to give a check here I just
got a burn some clock back to tournament
150
o 148 150 148 128 8 minutes
whoa this guy has more games in than
myself let's go let's go H pond okay
let's get my knight here and then I'm
insisting on it actually let's get out
of there bishop get out of there
and Bishop to d4 I want to hang on to my
light square bishop and I'm going to
Castle queenside or not no oh my knight
on c6 and my rook is there to kind of
watch over that here we go knight c6
this guy's fly I'm on the rook I almost
missed that and now what Bishop back and
stay here Bishop back and then do what
next actually just push here get on the
rook and play d6 next undermine this
opposition let's come back and now
there's okay now look for the King look
to kill the King next pile up weakened
squares as soon as that dark square
Bishop left I want I want that night I
want to keep the Queen's on the board
here we go Queen takes Knight oh I'm in
a pin again ah man that was a nice
defense that they just had their I'm on
the rook and looking for tricks Knight
here some how could I make that happen I
want to make that happen here
keep my king on a good square okay let's
come back here 15 seconds each
mother rook and the knight run their
time a little bit this is a key this is
a key game get that rope yes that's what
I needed right there
sneak the King up sneak them up some
more get rid of this Bishop next pile up
on that pun there we go get these guys
come over here stepladder may-who back
to tournament 170 166 oh it's gonna come
down and again how many times am I gonna
get paired up this is what the fourth
game oh you can't do that you're in a
pin come back home where it's safe go
home where it's safe Queen you know
what's good for you okay let's not trade
there the rook is gonna be very powerful
and okay Oh Oh tricky tricky stuff the
dark square Bishop is dead I'm going to
bring it back to d6 if it isn't taken or
Bishop to d7 Bishop d7 I want my Brooks
out I want my Brooks out and about I'm
gonna take like this okay let's
oh boy oh man okay wait tricks on us
c3 oh they missed it really resign are
they gonna resign here yes back to term
at 191 68 166 138 five minutes five
minutes this guy again this guy again
I've played him already once at least
and okay they might do a pawn push or
not okay no okay
take again and get my Night Out
queenside castle and then C 4 D 5 C 4 D
5 c4 but not D 5 now okay let's get my
bishop on the dark diagonal and my queen
on g4 but the bishop is going to play
here
recapture with my queen okay here we go
here we go chase that bishop off the
diagonal get my queen okay this has to
be good right chop here chop the night
soon enough Bishop takes Knight if the
Queen defends okay here we go
something with f5 hit the knight again
this has to be good right I actually
have something pawn takes Queen takes
Knight Queen takes or a queen h6 let's
go here I don't even know what that's
doing
okay Queen g5 Queen g5 and then Queen d2
stops everything crap but the Knights
dead actually
the Knights dead with g4 unless rook d4
there we go I got the night at least
they're down on time as well
oh boo boo that's the night that's the
night take that night watch out for the
seventh rank and maybe get them back
rank made against them back rank mate
back to tournament 210 210 206 168 this
is the only guy that could catch me 206
art art pug 210 206 three minutes left
oh man
oh we know he didn't overtake me I false
alarm right there - 210 206 it's going
to come down to the wire down to the
wire and okay alright okay let's get my
knight central and alright let's hang on
to this eise is weakened but um
hopefully I could deal with that
hopefully I could deal with that and
let's get Bishop here before my knight
is kicked away and I'm in trouble I'm in
trouble I'm in trouble
oh man I'm losing my bishop oh I'm not
losing my bishop Queen to b5 would have
been a killer okay I got
do this and so much for a fantastic
paunch structure right man it's so much
for a quick win - okay
let's hang on here I need to hang on to
some material could I please just um
hang on to some material here
okay okay keep pressure on that get my
king in a decent position run King let's
see if they let me get to have five okay
they did I can't take the pawn because
there'd be that move that they just
played
okay that's strong that's a strong move
my King has to run elsewhere he has to
run in a spot called elsewhere okay
let's take this and then is the rook
gonna take okay let's do that the king
is in a good spot
right there let's guard like this
laterally if pawn push I could take and
then take on e5 it might be tempting to
do that if rook here i guard the seventh
a very little time hit the bishop oh boy
I'm gonna keep my Bishop round if they
take the pawn let's go here maybe
there's something same thing I'm going
to keep my Bishop around let's put what
pressure that Bishop come on okay now
I'm gonna take it cuz I get this guy
next and I got to move fast let's hang
on to this guy hang on for a second I
should also just get out of this
position when I'm cut off hit the rook
oh oh I'm gonna take that rook if you're
gonna give me the rock I'm gonna take it
I promise
well usually no I didn't mean to do that
what am i doing so they're gonna take my
rep back Oh what am i doing what just
happened there no no the kit happened
yes point eight seconds to 30 34 seconds
six there's a six-point lead Jackson
Jackson needs to go down quickly come on
let's go here there it is what'd I get
yes I'll take it whew oh that was nuts
right there that was nuts
I took my opponent's rook I'm talking
about yeah I'm gonna take the rook and
then I give my rip right back Oh
and whoo let me close out of that one
crazy that's 40 crowns to 32:24 this guy
was right on my heels right to the end
he had 19 games in oh man good games all
nuts